es ist eine absolute sensation in der
jobs pyramide wurde eine neue riesige
geheime kammer entdeckt und das mit
teilchenphysik aber welche geheimnisse
verbirgt und wie kann sie jetzt erreicht
werden
jetzt endlich zum tricksen wie ist die
lage der geheimkammer in der jobs
pyramide herzlich willkommen die
ägyptologie ist eine der absolut
spannendsten wissenschaften immer wieder
werden neue geheimnisse und tausende
jahre alte artefakte entdeckt erst vor
kurzem zwei riesige statuen ägyptische
pharaonen und noch so einiges dürfte
unter dem wüstensand in ägypten
verborgen sein oder sogar direkt vor
unseren augen in den pyramiden immer
wieder wird dort gesucht mit immer
moderneren methoden erst vor einigen
jahren wurde mit einem roboter ein
seltsamer gang entdeckte aber im nichts
endete und jetzt jetzt haben
teilchenphysiker ein neues wirklich
großes geheimnis in der cheops-pyramide
entdeckt und das ist wirklich riesig
eine 30 meter lange und acht meter hohe
kamera oberhalb der galerie des ganges
der zur königs kammer führt aber wie
konnte die kammer jahrtausende verborgen
bleiben und wie konnte sie jetzt
entdeckt werden die teilchenphysik macht
es möglich erst mal ist das verfahren
simpel war aber bisher in dieser
größenordnung einfach nicht möglich
röntgen das durchleuchten von materien
mit strahlen die durch sie durchdringen
für uns menschen geht das ganz einfach
mit einem röntgengerät doch eines zu
bauen das so groß ist um eine pyramide
zu durchleuchten dass es schlicht und
einfach unmöglich deshalb kamen die
archäologen auf die findige idee sich
mit teilchenphysiker zusammenzutun
vielleicht gibt es ja teilchen die durch
die materie dringen und sowieso durch
den raum fliegen und genauso war es
millionen sind die lösung sie entstehen
wenn protonen aus dem weltall auf unsere
atmosphäre treffen dabei zerfallen
atomkerne und es entstehen diese
millionen sie sind wie elektronen
negativ geladenen zerfallen aber bereits
nach 22 millisekunden also war sie
schnell vom aus und betrachtet
existieren sie aber gott sei dank viel
länger die relativitätstheorie macht es
möglich sie bewegen sich fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit fort deshalb wirkt
die zeit der nation auf sie
sie haben für uns rund zehn mal mehr
zeit bis sie zerfallen
dieser zeit können sie die erdoberfläche
erreichen und auf dem weg durch materie
werden sie dann abgelenkt fliegen sie
nicht durch materie werden sie nicht
abgelenkt stellt man in einer pyramide
also unterhalb eines hohlraums
detektoren auf treffen dort mehr mehr
millionen auf als unter einer dicken
stein schicht wie mit einem röntgengerät
können jetzt auf diese weise hohlräume
entdeckt werden und genau das ist jetzt
passiert oberhalb der galerie muss es
nach den messungen der teilchenphysiker
einen riesigen raum geben 30 meter lang
und acht meter hoch aber was hat es mit
diesem hohlraum aufsicht die
spekulationen schießen jetzt ins kraut
von da gibt es keinen hohlraum über das
ist ein entlastung der wie in der königs
kammer den druck der steinmassen auf die
galerie darunter ableiten sollen bis zu
das ist die eigentliche grabkammer gibt
da sein meister im verstecken
noch ist alles ziemlich unklar sollte es
eine strenge kammer sein so glauben
angelogen und archäologen sei sie auf
keinen fall eine chance oder grabkammer
weil ja alles nach unten rutschen würde
die haben aber offensichtlich noch
nichts von stufen gehört man stelle sich
nur mal einen schrägen nach oben
ansteigen den riesigen raum voller
schätze vor
ein riesiger berg würde sich da vor
allem auf turm wahnsinn was für eine
perspektive die kann man könnte aber
auch einfach nur vage recht sein
da werden diese gegenargumente sowieso
makulatur aber wie kann man das jetzt
herausfinden ist es nur ein riesiger
staubiger raum oder eine schatzkammer
voller gold noch hat niemand eine idee
denn es scheint keine zugänge zu dem
raum zu geben und ob je eine bohrung
dazu zu diesem raum erlaubt wird das ist
äußerst fraglich wenn es neuigkeiten
gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann jagt ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke nur dann
verpasst er kann wie ihr das mit der
zeit die nation erklärt übrigens hier in
die relativitätstheorie einfach erklärt
danach habt ihr hoffentlich keine fragen
mehr und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran